il ya une discussion sur la date et vous
l'avez évoqué dans votre reportage il
faut savoir à quelle logique on obéit et
c'est un petit peu la même logique que
celle de la loi de 1955 sur l'état
d'urgence
nous avions décidé en mars quand nous
avons créé ce régime de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire il n'existait pas avant dans
notre droit nous avions dit le
gouvernement doit pouvoir le décréter
très rapidement donc par un décret et au
bout d'un mois
il faut qu'il passe devant le parlement
et le parlement pourra le proroger pour
une durée qui le définit et
souvenez-vous sur l'état d'urgence
classique entre 2015 et 2017 les
prorogations parfois été trois mois
parfois de cas parfois même de six voire
huit mois et donc là on est exactement
dans la même situation on a prorogé à
plusieurs reprises c'est la cinquième
fois que nous allons examiner un texte
sur l'état d'urgence
l'idée c'est de proroger jusqu'en
février et d'organiser également la
sortie tout cela dans le même texte
je voudrais juste rajouter j'ai fait le
compte à l'assemblée nationale on est à
80 heures de débats parlementaires sur
l'état d'urgence donc c'est extrêmement
important que le parlement délibère ce
n'est pas juste à la main du
gouvernement
mais après ça ne sert à rien de
délibérer tous les mois sur le sujet
sachant la longueur des débats et la
longueur de la navette parlementaire
album ps que tout de même ces
limitations à nos libertés dans la durée
elle vous inquiète vous l'avez dit c'est
la 5ème prorogation est ce qu'on va vers
l'état d'urgence permanent pas du tout
et justement c'est pour ça que l'on
vient devant le parlement on en discute
et nous on autorise le gouvernement pour
une certaine durée à utiliser un certain
nombre de pouvoirs
compte tenu d'une situation sanitaire
exceptionnel donc tout cela est
extrêmement un cadré est extrêmement bas
lisez donc ça n'a rien de permanent
en revanche il est impératif et tout le
monde peut le comprendre aujourd'hui que
à une situation sanitaire données il
nous faut une réponse juridique qui ont
résonné même de liberté face à des
impératifs de sécurité sanitaire où
l'entente que ça peut bien sûr que c'est
ça m'a inquiété mais vous savez à
l'assemblée nationale dans l'hémicycle
ya deux statues une qui représente
l'ordre public et une qui représente la
liberté et tous les textes tous les
actions doivent tenir compte de ces deux
impératifs là et là on a la scène
sécurité sanitaire de nos
citoyens c'est notre priorité et nos
libertés et il faut concilier les deux
votre commission des lois a créé une
mission d'information sur ce régime
juridique il est quand même fragile
juridiquement ce cadre d'état d'urgence
sanitaire alors il faut encore une fois
se reporter à ce qui s'est passé en mars
nous avions décidé une chose essentielle
s'était créé un régime d'urgence
sanitaire tout de suite le gouvernement
n'avait besoin pour protéger nos
concitoyens et en même temps c'était dit
mais on ne peut pas durablement installé
un régime justement d'exception dans
notre droit aussi rapidement donc il
faudra prendre le temps et on avait mis
une clause extinction donc au 31 mars
2021 le régime d'état d'urgence
sanitaire n'existera plus dans notre
droit est donc là moi ce que j'ai
souhaité à la commission des lois c'est
que nous puissions travailler dans la
durée
pouvoir auditionner des
constitutionnalistes regard faire du
droit comparé et avoir un petit retour
d'expérience le mettre dans la loi cette
possibilité de l'état d'urgence est
alors ça n'est pas éventuellement c'est
sûr parce que on aura besoin de pouvoir
actionner à ce régime juridique lorsque
l'on fera place à une situation
sanitaire exceptionnelle alors le projet
de loi habilite aussi à nouveau le
gouvernement à légiférer par ordonnance
est ce que le parlement risque une
nouvelle fois d'être un petit peu
escamoté dans la crise
le sénat a d'ailleurs créé lui une
délégation qui est spécialement là pour
contrôler l'application des lois par
ordonnance si on en tombe bien ses
inquiétudes
alors oui tout à fait il faut que le
parlement lorsque non habilite le
gouvernement continue à effectuer son
contrôle donc nous à la commission des
lois ont publié sur notre site
l'ensemble des ordonnances leur contenu
la date du projet doit de prorogation il
est extrêmement important d'effectuer le
suivi ça n'est pas du tout un blanc
simple parlement n'a pas été un peu
réduit à un rôle de spectateur dans
cette crise que l'on a vécu on a entendu
un des parlementaires qui l'ont regretté
mais il le regrette mais moi ça c'est
quelque chose que
je conteste absolument encore une fois
hier nous étions en commission des lois
nous avons auditionné le ministre de la
santé le ministre de l'intérieur les
débats se sont tenus sans aucune
limitation donc le parlement existe
après il existe différemment mais les
institutions fonctionnent et c'est la
solidité de notre vème république